[Music]
hello Marva lights you are watching this
weekend Marvin I'm Ryan aka agent m and
I'm so excited to be sitting here with
Dan de lluvia effects supervisor of
Marvel Studios Avengers endgame then
there's so many amazing moments and and
and shots inspired by the comics here in
Marvel Studios Avengers in gaming I was
looking at Secret Wars number four like
the classic you know mid 80s issue and
had this when you were younger like
that's impossible the Hulk's holding up
a giant mountain he's saving everybody
yep but then you have that moment in
endgame which is so cool you're going
through and you're looking back at your
old your favorite comics and just kind
of you know taking those ideas you know
in Civil War with Tony and cap you know
when I start a film it'll be you know
with with the team again with the
previous team all fine panels that I
like and then let's make a folder and
it's like okay this is one of your shot
shots and shots and then eventually or
they don't shoot it that way sometimes
you're like okay we're go back and
change that shot change of thank you to
the panel there's of course
Captain America wielding the only air
that has happened a couple times in the
comics but when did you find out that
that was gonna be a shot you guys didn't
put together when he saw it in Ultron
you know but he just kind of you know
half picks it up and you know the debate
is whether he's worthy he's not where
theater it's one of the first things we
started pre busy rights your first your
favorite seems first and you kind of go
nuts right they want something that's
you know two minutes long three minutes
long five minutes long you do something
that's 20 minutes long
you pull the best beats out of it and
those are what goes in the film you have
years and years of history but there's
some really more recent moments you know
they Hal hide your moment from Captain
America Steve Rogers that was right
before secret Empire trust me
or even cap fighting cap which has
happened multiple times in the comics
but recently that happened in secret
Empire or seeing rescue like amazing
moment with her and Tony
but that's only from invincible Iron Man
which is within the last 10 years
other specific errors you're looking at
you just look at any bit of Marvel
history you do a deep dive you know and
they just kind of let you find the
pieces that are gonna play the best for
you and I mean I think that's you know
that's that's the point you look at
these films and you look at you know for
a multitude of reasons why these are
successful but they're successful
because you love the characters and you
love the comics and kind of bringing in
just those moments for fans when they're
gonna recognize it if it's new again
it's the best part Dan part of the
journey is the end and that's the end of
this episode of this week in Marvel
thank you so much for being here
everybody watching and listening make
sure to pick up Marvel Studios Avengers
and game on digital
you